welcome back to pj chain design this is
pj today we are going to talk about this
twist pattern on the ring shank and also
how to create a hello calculated stone
for it are you ready let's get started
[Music]
there will be two different parts of
this video one is the top i want to show
you how to arrange the stone for this
header shape
and also the second part will be how to
making this twisted ring band that's
starting from a scratch first we are
going to bring in the stone and then you
can download the stone at the
description below sign up the newsletter
and i will have a stone link send it to
you and then we are also
going to start it with the ring size in
this case i want my ring size to be 8
which is the diameter to be 16. and i'm
going to move this strong to
the position that i want one thing i
wanted to mention is the
of the stone which is this point
right here you don't want to have it too
close to the ring if you set it up
really close to the ring and your
jeweler may
set it lower and that might cause the
problem
is stick it to the bottom of the ring
shank so i usually like to have at least
0.5 millimeter over there okay and then
once we have the stone we wanted to make
a bezel set and so let's go ahead to
draw a rectangle and i wanted to go
something look like this this will be
the bezel and i wanted to cut it no more
than 25 usually i will do about 20
of the stone you can make it tilted if
you want to
all right i intentionally make it a
little bit taller it's because you need
the jeweler need to push this wall
against the stone for setting right how
tall we need to have you can have like
really tall like this uh which will have
no problem but wastes a lot of material
so
over the table will be fine so that will
be first so let's go ahead to do the
surface by using the revolve we're gonna
pick up this one
snapping into the zero
holding the shift like this and click on
the screen and then you will get 360
degree and then you will get the bezel
it looked a little bit too tall but
that's fine this is for the stone
setting the one that i have uh this one
is more like a full rendering purpose
but in this case there's no way that you
can set a stone with not enough metal so
we want to make sure it's a little bit
taller for the stone setting purpose if
you have a history recorded sometime you
can do is you can make it a bit elegant
but i tilted it a little bit
and then move it in the same you don't
want to cut it more than 25 percent of
your prong and this will be the tilted
wall and sometimes it looks more elegant
that you can tuck in your head or stone
underneath it all right so once we have
that piece i'm going to make a copy of
this one
and then just simply scale it down 3d
scale it down to the proper size that
you like
and again i want to talking in this and
i also want to tilt it a little bit so
it's facing upward but tilt it a little
bit make sure that your stone is not
cutting into the wall and so i'm going
to move it out just a little bit
something look like this all right so we
need another place for this piece to sit
in so we are going to come into the
front view i'm going to draw another
rectangle for this to sitting and i want
to be long enough to make sure that it
passed the bottom of the ring shank
right and i also want to tilt it this
one the same angle with my stone and
kind of moving in a little bit all right
so you do want to have a stone where the
girdle is
flush with the
surface that you have uh you wanted to
have it to sit so i will adjust
something look like this
okay so now once you have it double
check on the top and see if it's
everything look all right if it does
let's give it a try and again you want
to record a history on the bottom and
let's go to the surface and then you got
revolve and then you want to snapping to
the zero
holding your shift and then we want to
do 360 degree and then we'll get another
surface like this
now when you have this surface i think i
need to adjust even a little bit more
to make it look flush right there all
right so when you have this surface i
usually like to do is having the rim
right here or the h right here to be
rounded so i want i'm going to use the
fitted edges first and i want to fit it
for something really small like 0.3
millimeter here
and just have a nice ring over there
maybe that is too much let's change it
to the 0.15
we just need to have a little bit of
room there so it doesn't look too sharp
over there it will break the history but
that's okay we're not changing anymore
all right so that's one piece right
there let's go ahead to give you the try
for arrange the stone with the polar
array command we want to snapping into
the zero and i'm going to try 16 of them
and see how's the arrangement
um let's do 360 degree as you can see
that now it's like
jamming back to each other
so i would like to do
is to
change into 15 and then it is a bit
better
i'm also going to change into the 14
and see how it goes
and it looks much better it basically
wanted to gap in between here it's about
0.1 to 0.2 millimeter and that's hit
enter so we got 14 arrangement right
there
in this case i like to go with the even
number so i will have one here one here
it look more symmetrical and those two
are aligned
so let's go back to
the perspective double check it look all
right if it does look alright let's go
ahead to creating a little prong i'm
going to create this very tiny
um
polyline right there and then we're
going to use the pipe command and i'm
going to pipe it roughly about
this size and we can adjust the size if
it doesn't work so first of all that's
moving in here this one ideally it's
going to be somewhere there and we are
going to visible to see if this prong
will fit it look like a prong is too big
so i'm going to 3d scale it down
because you don't want people just
looking at the prong you want them to
look at the stone and that's put it here
and double make sure that looks alright
and if that looks all right to you we
wanted to have another one put it right
there this one because it's in inside so
this can be a little bit smaller
once we have the prong size that you
like i'm going to have this one
coming over
close to the h right here and also
making a copy of the other one and
we're going to size it down a little bit
instead of moving there i actually want
to pick up both of them and i'm going to
use the rotate tool instead and snapping
into the zero
and kind of removing in this way if you
wanted to be particular you can you know
using 360 degree divided by the 14 and
then you can find a gap there all right
so i want this one going up a little bit
so i have enough prong to push over and
this prong we wanted to move it in a
little bit it might be too much all
right so double make sure they look
alright i'm going to moving in a little
bit
make sure it's covered on both sides of
the stone for something like this all
right i also want to make sure this
prong is not touching that wall and
that's great that we have it tilted so
it have a more space right there okay so
if that look okay to you we are going to
pick up those two prong and we are going
to use the same command for polar array
that's snapping into the zero and we do
the same number
for 14 of them and for 360 degree so
then we'll have the prong ready right
there okay so now everything is ready
all we need to do is pick up our ring
shank
and i want to make it into the solid by
extruded planar curve straight
and then i want to make sure both i
equal yes the solid equal yes on the top
and then we'll get something like this
now let's go ahead to pick up this
special and this bezel and that's
pulling different from here so then we
have the top part is done and then you
also have a space open there sometimes
you save the money on your metal you
might want to cut it off this much right
here so that will save you a lot of the
metal weight here so you can make it the
bottom
more open all right
i will leave that to you and show you
how to make the ring shank
in the ring shank wise i would like to
having a ring chain go into the angle
more like this way so it's like coming
tapered from the bottom going to the top
ending somewhere over there
you can adjust this line if you want to
go
in more or less all right so i'm going
to stay something like that we need to
have a circle
that circle is um
following this
tilted angle there so the command we are
going to use is curved front two view
and with curved front two view i'm going
to pick up this one and this one it will
automatically creating
this curve right there and this is the
curve it's going to follow
this tilted line with this curve right
there i need to creating the pattern so
let's see how long is it by using the
command for length
and with the lens command is showing me
that it is 50.555
so i'm gonna copy that
number and i'm going to draw a straight
line with the polyline and that's
starting anywhere right here and copy
that
50.555 there and then this is the length
of this red line if it is being
straightened and something over here
okay so then i'm gonna coming over here
to my um right view to work on it but
it's hard to see where this line is on
my right view so i simply just going to
put the
point right there okay so that's coming
into the right view you see that point
over there and that's the beginning of
that line we're going to create in the
pattern by drawing
circle
and the circle roughly going to look
like this and i'm going to move it
somewhere about this place
now once i have this circle i'm going to
using that point as a center and we're
going to use the polar array command and
using the circle snapping to the point
as the center and i wanted three of them
you can have more if you want to it's
just coming into a different pattern
once you have that let's go ahead to
pick up all of them and using the trim
command and then we want to trim
everything in the middle so like this
one this one this one we want to get rid
of them and i'm also going to join them
as well so now we have the circle over
there
you also want to measure if this is the
length you want so far i have it here
it's
1.78 which is fine because after you
rotate it they might get a bit better
but i don't like to have a sharp corner
here so i'm going to give it a fitted
edges as coming into the curve tool you
have the
fitted corners now for the edges for
the edges for the solid so for the
corners i want to pick up here
and i want to fill the edge maybe just
like point one
and to give it like really nice and soft
it just
soft corner there and let's take a look
on this all right so i'm going to have
this one just align
with my point because i was drawing on
the construction plane so we want to use
the align tool on the right and make
sure everything is aligned over there
okay so now we have this right here i'm
going to make it into the solid by
having this one extruded
planar curve straight
and we don't need the both side here you
just need one side we want to go all the
way snapping into that end right there
okay so how we're going to make a twist
uh we're going to use the twist command
and let's go ahead to pick up this piece
and coming into the twist command
and we wanted to snapping into the
endpoint of that curve and also end
point of
the other end and then we want to do
10 term
5 6 7
8 9 10. you actually need to physically
to rotate a 10 term there
and once you're done you'll get
something like this
notice that this is 2n is a bit loose
right there
it's because in the setting we have an
infinitive setting now as a preset but
that's okay because that piece is going
to be inside we're going to cut it
now one thing really important we need
to know where is the seam of this curve
so we can coming over here and then we
can pick up the seam and you will show
the seam is right there i want to seam
is going to the middle top
of that circle so this two end will end
the inside of the hello there okay so
let's go ahead to flow another thing is
currently we have this reference curve
right in the middle i wanted to move it
down to the bottom
sometime you can do is you can pick up
both of the shape and we're just using a
line to the bottom
right there
so that way it won't cut inside of the
ring shank all right so now let's give
it the try we want to use the command
under the transform that you have
flow a long curve and you're going to
pick up this piece first hit enter pick
up the curve that you have
and then we're gonna pick up the target
curve all right so now you can see this
is coming
into correct position make sure it's not
cutting inside of a ring shank and if
that look okay to you you can come into
the right view and then we're gonna use
the mirror command snapping into the
zero
and then you want to copy to the other
side and then that will be the ring that
you have as a split twisting ring with
the header setting if you like the way i
model check out the membership program i
have a lot more tips and tricks wanted
to share with you hope to see you in the
membership thank you for watching and i
will see you next
[Music]
foreign